let's check in with a couple of other
people like our next caller from the
five-10 area code caller from five-10 go
ahead
hey what's going on Dave hi my name is
intermediary Joe and I'm from San
Francisco California so my question is I
don't know if you've read some Harris's
essay on riddles that guy what he talks
about the idea of like making it a gun
license as difficult to get is like a
pilot's license I was just curious what
is your opinion on that what do you
think about the whole idea of repealing
the Second Amendment okay well those are
two completely different so let's do you
want me to answer them in parts sure
yeah okay I've not read that essay from
Sam Harris I am in favor of the idea of
making it significantly more difficult
and rigorous to obtain a firearms
license there are some states where it
already is more difficult than in others
there are places there are cities where
it is even more difficult than it is
within those states and I think that
getting a license for a gun should be
much more difficult
I think firearms should have to be
insured in the way that automobiles are
insured and I am completely in favor of
that I think that repealing the Second
Amendment is a total non-starter and
even if I could make a moral case for it
it is one of those things like when
Democrats started talking about Trump's
kids having birthright citizenship no
they don't
don't mention it don't talk about it it
hurts your credibility because it's just
not practical and I was curious what
about do you have an opinion on like a
semi-automatic gun ban or do you feel
like that's in the same categories like
the repealing the Second Amendment like
it might be out of like the Overton
Window the problem about a total
semi-automatic gun ban even if we could
defend it morally if we could defend it
legally if we could defend it
mathematically is that so many guns are
semi-automatic like I think a lot of
people don't understand that
semi-automatic means you know you pull
the trigger once and one round fires and
then you pull the trigger again and
around fires and there are just too many
guns that fall under that that we are we
are simply I think it's a non-starter I
just don't think it's it's productive to
even talk
about that I think there's lower hanging
are they focusing on would you ever be
interested in any kind of future like
Skype interview or anything like that
I'm sorry would I be interested in a
Skype interview yeah with who myself
I've done some pretty good interviews I
think you probably know Cameron Kathy
Brandon Tatum just I don't know them but
really I don't know who those people are
but email me and we can we can talk
about that thank you for the call really
appreciate it